Speaking of love birds, if you're out there
and you're dreaming of getting married in Italy,
maybe you two, hey!
You're in luck, there's good news.
"Insider" reports, a region called Lazio,
which includes Rome, is offering couples around the world.
They're offering them money!
$2,230 to get married there.
And, yeah, the campaign is called from Lazio with Love.
And their goal is to revive the local economy.
And couples can apply online.
All you have to do is spend the money that they give you
there in the town locally on flowers, dresses,
venues, catering, photographers.
And, you know, I feel like I've done my part for Italy
'cause I've been to Olive Garden so many times, you know?
(audience laughing)
And you're welcome.
But, I don't know, getting paid $2,200 to get married there,
it's kind of a cute incentive, right?
I'm so into this.
Yeah, right.
I love it!
They're ponying up.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I mean, okay, real talk,
they're putting in 10 million dollars
into you the commerce of their city
and the thriving livelihood.
Apparently 17,000 couples about, approximately,
used to get married there annually
and now it's only like 9,000 because of the pandemic.
And business is down, so they're trying to revitalize
by doing this initiative.
I just feel like this is so romantic
and I've so many friends that are getting married.
I know, and I'm not getting paid for it,
I'll tell you that much.
This sounds pretty good as I'm planning right now.
You know what I respect?
If a town doesn't have an industry
that's bringing in revenue, create it.
Yes!
And so now they're telling people let's become
the wedding capital of Italy.
Come here, find out why we're amazing.
Good for you, Lazio, it's very smart to get people there.
I love this story!
(audience applauding)
Well done Lazio!
Everybody get your love on and go to Lazio.
This is not the trailer they want for their commerce.
They're fine with it.
They're like, no!
(Ross laughing)
Was that an Italian, by the way?
Yes, it was.
(Ross laughing)
(upbeat music)